all right let's talk a little bit about
climate because it's become fairly clear
to anyone paying attention that as we
shift out of covid mania the system the
machine is going to need more craziness
to further lock down further control us
further figure out ways to manipulate us
further figure out ways to keep us
scared and angry and everything else and
I do sense and I really do that the
covid thing is starting to uh I would
say close up like they're not going to
stop with the fear-mongering and
everything else but I think a lot of
people are finally just moving on I
really believe it so they've got to
figure out something else because they
can't have you walking around not in
fear just thinking straight and looking
around and seeing the world around you
and making individual thoughts and
choices for yourself they can't have
that right so they got to keep the Kobe
thing going so here's some video of Jen
saki she is back after she got coveted
and had to take about 10 days off she
was vaccinated for kovitz somehow got
covered don't tell Joy Behar that would
be very setting and I think what saki
says here kind of lends itself to the
way that they are going to uh increase
the fear take a look just to be clear I
know that's been a criticism so that's
why I said that not an accurate one look
our view is that the rise in gas prices
over the long term makes it an even
stronger case for doubling down our
investment and our focus on clean energy
options so that we are not relying on uh
the fluctuations and OPEC and their
willingness to put more Supply and meet
the demands in the market
man it's so dangerous what she said
right there if you really listen to what
she's saying she's basically going yeah
gas prices are rising so we're gonna
have to do more of our green stuff our
recycling stuff our renewable stuff now
I'm not against Green things I'm not
against uh doing all sorts of things
related to say nuclear power I know that
scares these people even though it's
deeply deeply safe and we now know that
and they're trying to close all these
nuclear power plants but what she's
saying is as gas prices rise we're gonna
have to do more of all that stuff that
we've been trying to push down your
throats with Bill back better and our
crazy bills and lunatic AOC and
everything else so wouldn't it behoove
them then to actually
raise gas prices wouldn't if you really
believe that you wanted to transfer
everybody over to green power and the
green New Deal and their green
dystopia although they believe it's a
Utopia wouldn't you then do everything
you could to make gas as expensive as
possible wouldn't you do everything you
could to destroy the economy if you're
really saying we have to build back
better we have to completely change
things and by the way this is what
they're saying right they're telling us
that what an opportunity there is after
kovid to really look at how we do
everything in America and fundamentally
change things and you silly silly decent
liberals the last 20 of you that thought
that old Joe Biden was going to stop it
he has ushered it in more than
absolutely anyone else so it would
actually benefit the people who want us
to get to this green thing that will
never really work and is going to cause
so many problems and cause actually all
sorts of uh depression for uh poor or
people I discussed that with Jordan
Peterson like the best way to help poor
people is through cheaper energy
resources right but that's not really
what they're interested in check out my
interview with Jordan Peterson from last
week if you want to get a little bit
more on that but basically she's telling
you the part that she's not supposed to
tell you we're happy when gas prices go
up and perhaps we would do everything we
could to make gas prices go up and by
the way we're kind of happy when the
supply chain gets screwed up because
then that kind of proves that capitalism
doesn't really work so we'll have to
figure out ways to maybe socialize uh
the system right we'll have to make sure
that our infrastructure system has far
more government involvement and much
less capitalist competition that would
make sense so they're telling you what
they're doing and if you don't think
that's enough we saw this video over the
weekend I saw this one
this is the Minister of environment and
climate change of Canada you know we've
been going through this big climate
conference these people all fly in their
private jets across the world most of
them like Barack Obama live in 11
million dollar Estates in Martha's
Vineyard right on the water you'd think
they'd move Inland but they don't it's
very weird uh well Stephen Bilbo who is
the Minister of environment and climate
change in Canada uh had a something very
interesting to say about climate and I
think you'll see the intersectional
nature of this stupidity Mr chair I
would like to say that Canada strongly
support strong languages on the rights
of indigenous peoples and the inclusion
of their traditional knowledge in in the
fight against climate change as well as
the protection of human rights as part
of this text thank you very much Mr
Speaker
okay I have no problem with indigenous
people right that's just fine if you
your people came from a certain place
and you're still there and you're doing
your thing but do you see by the way
they combine all of these things climate
change has absolutely nothing to do with
indigenous people he talks about the
traditional knowledge of indigenous
people to fight climate change is there
something that an indigenous person by
their birth knows more about climate
change than say the average scientist
who perhaps has been studying it who
maybe didn't come from the place that
they live on now like most of us and
most of our families and most of our
history most of man's history is a
history of people moving all over the
world in all sorts of Wars have been
fought and civilizations have grown and
civilizations have crumbled like is
there anything is there anything he says
the traditional knowledge of indigenous
people
it's a completely nonsensical statement
but they love it they love it again they
just clap on oh my God indigenous
both traditional knowledge we like
traditional knowledge somehow it's
against capitalism we like being against
capitalism
these people are so boring anyway I tell
you all of this just to say uh start
watching out for this the next thing
that's coming is the climate stuff there
will be climate lockdowns they will not
want cars on the road they will tell you
to stay in your house and use less heat
when it's cold and use less air
conditioning with it when it's hot and a
whole bunch of other stuff it's just on
the way I'm gonna fight it why not